welcome everybody to
session 11 of our classic metal class we
do this
monthly more or less schedule permitting
and this time we're doing something a
bit different uh before we do
before we jump into that i'm gonna
introduce my my co-host scott tarrouli
good friend of mine
fellow metalhead who came up with the
music
in in a different location but basically
in the midwest right
and so we have we we've got a lot of uh
back and forth stuff that we've been
talking about over the years and we
decided to start this show so that we
could have kind of an excuse
to do it and we we explore intersections
between
philosophy and heavy metal sometimes
doing a bit more music history but
always
bringing in some topics from say
metaphysics
or conceptions of identity or cause and
effect or
ethics and so it's it's been a a lot of
fun today we're talking about
um polling scott is a practicing
musician he's
he's played with a number of different
artists bands done a lot of studio work
he's a
guitar professor at berkeley school of
music he's a band leader
he's got several albums out so and he
he's actually going to be talking too
about tech stuff
uh we we are as we were prepping this
there there's a lot of tech stuff that
might come
in here and um yeah we we've
been studying philosophy together for a
number of years
anything else you want to say by way of
introduction for yourself scott
oh no that's about it um just something
kind of cool and funny that i came to
greg years ago from seeing his videos
and um i sent him an email through his
website and said you know i'm interested
in
studying more about rhetoric yeah and
when we were going through the rhetoric
we uh greg would always want to bring it
to a
modern day you know how we would use it
today and all of our examples became
metal examples okay yeah so let's say
we've got the band
you know kits and you know somebody you
know paul stanley treated someone like
this
and after a while it just became our
go-to for me to figure out how to use
the concepts and we just had a ball
always talk about and then i think one
day you had the idea of saying hey
we can actually you know talk about some
of this stuff
you know yeah i i it's i mean
philosophy works best when there's lots
of examples and
and this ties in before we jump into
today's stuff a little bit of a
digression
so there are some philosophers who think
rhetoric is really important and
and scott mentioned you know we were
studying rhetoric together we were
studying aristotle
because aristotle thought that unlike
plato who is very
anti-rhetoric rhetoric is is really
important and rhetoric is being able to
adapt yourself to an audience and you
could call it showmanship in a way
if we're thinking about musical stuff
somebody who was really great at it that
we are
we're uh just you know observing the
birthday of was
is the late great ronnie james deal you
watch him engage with anybody in an
interview and it's
amazing how he can zoom in figure out
what's on their mind
adapt what he wants to say to them
and so you know aristotle cicero other
other authors it turns out that
rhetoric is quite important in
philosophy and so
you know scott scott was an audience
where we could talk
metal and as it turns out the two kind
of illuminate each other there's there's
a lot of things where if you know a good
bit about metal
you can use that to make sense out of
philosophical
principles or arguments in very
interesting ways and
maybe maybe we'll do some of that today
i don't know i'm sure it'll come up
i'm sure it'll come up you know when we
talk about the you know the different
era some of these bands are career bands
they were yeah
three-month bands that were had one hit
on the radio
yeah they all have pretty massive
catalogs
that's that's for sure so the topic that
we're talking about today
is um what makes
best albums best and i think this
actually came out scott you'll have to
tell me if i'm wrong about this
you and i were kicking around the idea
of like determining
four given bands what's actually their
best album
and we were saying oh that's really
tough to say you know the better the
band
the harder it is to to figure out like
it's easy to say oh top five albums or
something like that
but to say this one is the best and to
have some not just like a gut reaction
but to have some sort of reasonable
grounds
that might be convincing to another
person it's tough to come up with
is is that how we got to talking about
this well
we came up with a list of criteria which
we'll be discussing
but wait a minute like what do you mean
like the album that introduced me to the
band or the one that
i heard the night of my prom or you know
ml reasons
or was it yeah like you said what
what am i judging my decision on you
know yeah
i think you know before we go in and
i'll be using this i was thinking about
it
it's kind of like um you know you
mentioned you know kind of is popular
i mean it's the best well you know i'll
i'll i'll have you know kids
they'll all know don't stop believing by
journey but that's because it was on
the sopranos it was the last and
everybody knew that song suddenly
or included in guitar hero oh and that's
a big one and then
stroke by billy squire was in some movie
so they all knew it and it's the only
billy squire song they knew but does
that mean it's his best
or just because it was part of pop
culture research in
pop culture yeah well
let's let's jump in so we we decided uh
in order to make the discussion
manageable and to focus a bit
we would talk about five major classic
metal bands
um three of them are british one of them
is an american artist
one of them is german so we picked iron
maiden judas priest
motorhead dio including ronnie james dia
which had some bleed over into rainbow
and black sabbath and then
the german band accept and what i did is
i pulled fans of my social media on
twitter youtube and facebook so
obviously not a scientific
you know polling with with great
accuracy but i just wanted to get some
useful
suggestions and input and see where
other people were
and i also compiled some stuff from
karang and from loudersound
that kind of dovetailed with that
we might do more episodes like this on
other key eras or scenes so maybe 1970s
metal talking about
black sabbath deep purple you know ufo
and then pick another one
or the la scene or thrash but we're
going to stick with like
what we can call traditional or you know
the core of heavy metal for this one
and when we're thinking about this
question as scott mentioned
it's not a popularity contest we don't
want to say oh well who's who sold the
most
albums because that doesn't necessarily
mean that it's the best album
it just means that things aligned in in
the right way
i mean a great example of this is look
at metallica
post cliff burton i would say that
the best stuff is the cliff burton era
but they went on to sell way way more
albums
afterwards when when they uh you know
sort of like hit hit on the right
registers all at the same time
when you have you know laura lyon the
gilmore girls debating with her daughter
whether
it's the offspring or metallica that
they should be listening to you're in a
whole different world than like the
original we could say setting of of
heavy metal
so we can't just go by album sales or
polling casual fans
you're not going to get at the real
stuff so then what's the real stuff
that's the question we're trying to
settle here and whose views should we
be taking into consideration you know we
want to take into
consideration those who have experience
you know
and so that that would be both me and
scott uh on this sort of thing you know
we grew up
with and maybe some of our viewers and
uh interlocutors growing up within that
that era probably gives you some
insights then again you know having some
retrospective looking at it could also
be helpful
but also expertise and this is where
scott is is particularly important
i can talk about you know why for
example peace of mind is a good
contender for being the best iron maiden
album
i don't have the technical chops quite
so much to talk about that
um except maybe in lyrical content or
something along those lines where scott
can tell us why the sound sounds the way
it does
and why you know when we get to the
uh killer to to filler stuff maybe why
some of that
is the way it is so let's start out with
talking about one of our first
poll we started with iron maiden yeah
and the polling was kind of interesting
uh but we're going to do the same thing
i'm going to give you the results of my
polling
uh somebody else then scott will present
his pick and why he thinks it is that
case
i'll present mine and then we're going
to open it up to q a
and um discussion so when i pulled
number of the beast came out as number
one
closely followed by the seventh son of
the seventh son and then
peace of mind power slave in somewhere
in time and so this is kind of
interesting because what it shows us is
there's a key
era that a lot of people think to be
like the
the definitive maiden era running from
number the beast to somewhere in time
and then seventh sun is kind of an
interesting outlier
there were other people who said other
albums you know killers got a few
but not an awful lot brave new world got
a few fear of the dark
but those were the ones that were really
big now paul
travers in karang and i i wanted to go
to like the best metal
magazine i thought to get this
when he did this polling seventh son was
kind of a runaway
winner followed by power slave number
the beast somewhere in time and peace of
mind so you notice it's the same five
right there's some consistency there
um but how it figures in is a little bit
uh
a little bit different so
before we do that what do you make of
this
this consistency and divergence scott
what do you think
you know i was really curious when you
put it up if seventh sun if that era of
the summer and time seven sun era was
gonna get
any love at all um now why
i think they're great albums but like
for the hardcore fans it was i remember
when those albums came out
much like turbo which we'll be talking
about you know they introduced
a slick sound and keyboards yeah and so
i think
for people our age at the time that was
kind of like a
a jolt like you know you go to the
record store
you buy the album and you put on your
turntable and you go what band is this
but you know it's interesting now with
you know even the younger generation
they're having a chance to look back at
the album that came out 35 years ago
you know probably um 20 years before
they were born
and go well this is cool you know i
think there's a difference in the
audience
so i'd be curious of people's age
that that vote oh yeah if we had if we
had those stats that
that could make a difference because i
have a lot of students at berkeley that
are 7th sun fans and i am too
i love that album but i mean is it my
favorite
um probably not but i think what to make
of it is
i think all of them have really strong
writing i mean
piece of peace of mind uh well even
killers let's go to killers where they
had less of a budget
or the the first album where they had no
budget
you know so you're talking it's complete
attitude and then you have a huge budget
at seventh sun
but you still have great writers i mean
yeah but adrian smith
and of course um that's interesting
because the the
really early stuff we're talking
primarily steve harris
doing the writing and as time goes on we
see adrian smith getting more and more
of a role in it i mean do you think we
can associate this somewhere in time in
seven sun
we can say well what happens is there's
much more influence of adrian smith on
on the sound
yeah i mean smith wrote um uh wasted
years
which is a must play in their set um
and adrian said he preferred those two
albums i think that's why they split
from what i understand he just said he
wanted to keep doing the seventh son
thing
the man wanted to go back to being kind
of a rock thing and so he went off and
did adrian smith and project which was
um not exactly somewhere in time but you
know
yeah we're polished
okay so what is your pick
um so this is iron maiden albums you got
to pick just one
yeah um it was
it was a toss-up between um
killers um
if we're looking at like the paul diano
era well we talk about this distinction
between
clive burr and paul diana where it was
like i love clyde versus drumming the
rhythm section was amazing
um they were an amazing band and they
were young and hungry and they barely
had any money and it was
kind of like the performance came
through on the album but i'm gonna have
to go
um all in all with peace of mind
which has okay fantastic songs on it
really fantastic songs
and um the production is great you know
for for the time that that came out it
was mixed really well i just
feel like um yeah everybody's choice for
sounds
you know there wasn't a whole lot of
sounds on that album as far as like they
weren't playing with keyboards they
weren't
super they weren't putting many effects
on the guitar
but the way that it was played um had
attitudes
of course when they went and did the
tour well greg and i
agreed that no live albums because you
could argue it's a best of
but um then the live versions you know
i've seen made in a bunch of times of
these songs are
pretty outstanding and i think just for
a song
as far as song and kind of being in that
raw era peace of mind
and it was really hard for me that was
the hardest one
it's very hard for me too and i'm
actually going to say killers
um i if if i was doing a listing peace
of mind would come second for a lot of
the same reasons i think peace of mind
is
is one of the the consistently heavy
albums um i really like the sound
on it and it's got some you know
absolutely killer
tracks killer killers i mean
maybe i'm making a wrong decision in
this because
so the studio album you know it's paul
diano
who's not bruce dickinson um
paul deano is good but not great i would
say
but the songs are really great and once
you actually have bruce dickinson in
there singing them
they shine more than with paul diano and
i was you know i was thinking like steve
harris's bass playing
i think one of the things that attracted
me to iron maiden in the very beginning
was i the first album i had was peace of
mind and those
constant base fills that he's doing
it it's just incredible it's like
oh i'm blanking on the name of the
drummer who neil pert with with um
drumming for for rush you never know
what's happening next right
but it always fits steve harris is like
that on the base
and i think that's part of what set iron
maiden apart from
some of their competitor bands at the
time
but that's their on killers and
the guitars are maybe a little bit less
uh assertive on on killers than they are
in the first two albums than they are on
the albums after that but
i think killers that's the one for me so
let's open this up to
our participants and see what what do
they think is the best iron maiden album
and and why um
[Music]
well that that's what we're really most
interested is the why
criteria why yeah but it's interesting
we both pick killers
um you have to remember like you know
they didn't have a lot of money
for mastering for yeah you know a lot of
these bands would say okay well the
cheapest the studio is 2 a.m to 5 a.m
and you have to go in there and set up
and record in those hours where now
where later on our maiden could spend a
year and make an album if they wanted
that's that's that's crazy going in that
time at night
yeah having the performance come out
that good i mean um there's something to
say about the
the age you're at you know it's kind of
like the old saying with musicians
or what happened to miles davis a lot
it's like why don't you why aren't you
putting out albums like when you were 18
that was like the real raw stuff and the
answer is always because i'm not 18
anymore and so and i always see albums
as a snapshot of that time
you know sometimes we see artists that
become a put on of themselves where
it made sense when they were in their
early 20s to be that reckless
but then they're in their 50s you know
though
um with iron maiden
and i think we can say this about quite
a few of the other artists that we're
looking at while we're waiting for
people to
to weigh in um so
consistently good albums coming out
almost like on the year you know
um along with tours going on
that's that's pretty amazing to be able
to do right because you got iron maiden
1980 right killers is 81 i think and
then
number of the beast 83 peace of mind 84
or as power slave 84. i thought i
thought somebody was 83
83 yeah so they're a fortiori right
it's even closer time and
they're just churning these out and
touring and
and doing all the other things you know
going on on tv shows and stuff like that
here's ken uh he says peace of mind
top-notch songwriting includes a classic
lineup with bruce and nico has an
amazing production that stood the test
of time i think that's
that's very true yeah yeah i agree
there's nothing dated
about peace of mind right phenomenal
album is maiden at their very best i
wish they'd remaster it with an
additional part for
for yannick no that's going to make
scott mad
you're not a big yannick fan right oh i
mean he he seems like a wonderful person
i don't
um just being an artist myself but i you
know
greg and i joke when yannick stayed in
the band
it was kind of he doesn't match up with
the other players he doesn't
his time isn't the same and um
you know he just took over a bunch of
the solos live
and didn't play them as well and um a
lot of people say he's a great showman
but um i don't know maybe it's just the
cranky old man in me going that's not
the
real old band but um you know
he's a fine player um i just it's you
know sometimes it's just kind of like i
don't think he's a
he was the best choice for maiden but
you know he stood the test of time and
how long has he been in there since 1990
yeah
actually that that basically makes him
now
an integral part of it chris says number
one
peace of mind because nico completes the
classic sound
number two number of the beast because
bruce debuts now that's an interesting
thing a lot of people did in fact say
that in my informal
polling they were like well you know
this is the album where this guy
came on power slave because uh rhyme
uh i think probably so great not
not not so great right and then oh here
so here's a question for you
uh chris says he wants to hear your
opinion on the 2015
made in remasters if i'm
okay there was a series of remasters
that was garbage because
what remastering is for those of you
that don't know what actually happens
they take the original tapes what
happened when we had cds first is
they simply dumped the mastering from
the lp onto a cd
and so you remember back in the day
where we have like a aad
analog analog digital or ddd
meant it was original from the beginning
uh digital from the beginning
what they do with the remaster is
they're supposed to raise the levels
um like the best remastering i ever
heard was the steely dan box set
i forgot the guy that did it um but
mastering will make or break an album
yeah well the 2015 ones
that whoever there became a trend
where and i still buy these albums that
are pretty much
white noise so the compression about 13
or
15 is pushing it some of these are
compression of three which is ridiculous
so i got somewhere in time because it
had they had it in stock at the store
and it i put it in my car and it was it
was white noise i couldn't hear
and the drums and the vocals were in the
same register because compression means
you
squish it all okay and the reason they
squish it is because it's
louder and people are like we want our
album to be louder than the next
person's
not you know and these are a r people
calling the shots not musicians
they don't understand that we have a
volume knob and when you play stuff on
the radio everything's the same volume
because they have their own
compression so you know
to give you an honest answer i'm trying
to think maybe because they did a few
remasters of the 2015
those were okay but the one of the
rematches i bought a few of them
and it was just it was garbage and i
wanted my money back the original
sounded better because they were making
squishing it so much they wanted the
volume to be loud and that's something
you know when if you purchase the cd a
lot of the new bands
you'll hear and
yeah and when the drums when the vocals
come in the snare drum disappears
that's a good thing to listen to i think
for i think for a lot of bands
particularly in the metal genre but i
mean this could apply to others
you definitely want to be able to hear a
separation between
what the bass is doing compared to what
the guitar is doing
even if they're playing even if they're
doing the thing where they're doubling
up on the same
riff you know like think about old black
sabbath stuff you want to be able to
hear
uh butler's base and iomi's guitar is
separate things
and i think some of the remastering can
can lose that right
and uh well just chris maybe you know
maybe those are the ones
god time just flies maybe those are the
ones i picked up
and i know there's a big gap there's
about 20 years gap in that but
um didn't they so ken says they got
didn't they get disowned by steve harris
i i don't know that's a good question
you mean the masters yeah i think that's
that's it yeah
well that happened to gene simmons um
everybody said that was
uh oh the 98 remasters he's saying
oh okay good okay so i have to pick up
the 2015. i have a lot of the original
ones and i've got them on vinyl
but um people backstage were complaining
years ago when kiss remastered their
stuff or
pre they're like you know your cds sound
awful
so gene simmons actually went to a
record store and bought a bunch of kiss
cds and put them in and said you know
what
they're right and then he had all the
kit catalog
remastered so interesting thing
yeah that's that's definite quality
control there
so uh well let's let's jump into talking
criteria so
we wanted to use the iron maiden one as
a launching point
um i mentioned that we we don't want
this
we don't want to like try to have a
popularity contest thing
why not well because it's an in it's
what we can call an extrinsic criteria
it's something
accidental something contingent
some other criteria that are more that
way they're not really on point
it's the first album i listened to some
people chose
you know various albums because of that
and you can say well that's cool that's
part of your backstory
but why would that make it best you know
best in a more objective sense rather
than just
best for for you um
it's it's subjective in the
problematic sense meaning arbitrary like
if i went by that criterion then i would
indeed pick
um peace of mind for my you know it was
the first iron maiden album i listened
to
defenders of the faith for a judas
priest
but i'd be picking motorhead's
orgasmatron and that's definitely not
their best album
you know um or
well with with the other two i mean
except uh balls to the wall is the one i
picked and i i do actually think that's
their their best album
um but you know it's really arbitrary
what what
first album somebody encountered right
we want to be able to say
why something is better now another
really
interesting criterion a historical
criterion
that was giving a given is um
the album is important because it was
influential on other bands
so there were a lot of people who said
except restless and wild
and motorhead's overkill were their best
why because they kicked off speed metal
arguably uh that that is the case
you could say a similar thing then like
you'd have to think about like well
what's the best venom album
obviously black metal because that you
know kicks off
black metal it's definitely not their
best produced album
um i don't know if it's even their best
album but that
that is kind of interesting to think
about that historical
role you know would that mean that that
black sabbath's black sabbath is their
their best album um which
i mean you could make a case for that
but i don't you know
i don't know i mean what do you think
about this scott this this making
something
the best album because it kicks off a
kind of
new history it's uh it's really an
argument from innovation um you know
what's interesting before i answer
and i'm just saying this because craig
uh greg posted something very cool
um uh a tribute to dio and some of it
was his interviews
and there's one where dio's on a tour
bus
and they hand him each album he was on
from the very first one
and there's some criteria that i'm
seeing deal go by
you know he'll say well this was an okay
record but it's really important to me
because this is the first time
i got to play with richie blackmore and
then you know so he put this in the good
pile
um but not because he thought it was the
best performed album
or this was great because i got to work
with so and so
yeah yeah it was a slow process so even
the artists themselves
have but i like how he made the
distinction of okay this is great
but he'll say you know not because the
performance of the songs were the best
but it's important to me so i think that
you're saying this we're kind of the
same saying the same thing in the sense
that like
as far as a movement um uh i'm trying to
think
um yeah i mean we could we could look at
the we've talked about this a number of
times
influence um how does how does influence
actually work causally
sociologically what is influence you
know when you look at
bands in the 1980s like say in the
thrash
scene right you ask them okay well who
are your your main influences
and they'll say like oh iron maiden and
judas priest
um you know motorhead and then they they
often in the interviews don't go much
further than that but sometimes they
will actually mention an
album that was like key for them you
know lars ulrich was somebody who would
do that
andy had something kind of interesting
here coming back to the
like first album i i listened to
she said um peace of mind is the first
she heard
that that might be the reason but it
will always hit a bit differently that
said can i play with madness 22 acacia
avenue wasted years or songs i'd feel
sad
or cheated if i didn't hear in concert
yeah
because it opened up my way of
experiencing them as a band and i think
that's
i mean that's an important topic in its
own right
this the what what's different about
like sitting in your
your you know bedroom with your
turntable
and going out to see them as a band
you know like sometimes you you can go
and
the performance can be very similar to
what you're actually hearing on the lp
and people sometimes feel cheated that's
the case right they're like i couldn't
just stay at home and listen to the
the album i want to hear something a bit
different you want the live experience
you want
you uh i always say as far as
performance you want the experience for
better for worse of the band that day
you know if we were talking iron maiden
bruce dickenson didn't get his cup of
tea before and he's mad
or you know um they played soccer that
day and it didn't go well or you know
and i think that's part of any kind of
live
art is um you know sometimes you'd hear
like live out i'd hear live albums that
were bootlegs and
they weren't quite right but there was
something to them so i kept listening to
them it's like
well you know the drums are dragging a
little bit here and here but there's
something kind of cool the the
snapshot of that moment even though it's
not perfection then there's bands out
there
i know we all know that are playing to
tracks um and then we we went we had
that whole debate of
well should we have dio as a hologram no
because dio can't respond to the energy
of the crowd you're not getting a live
experience
this is more of like a you know to me
it's it's it's if the crowd's dull
deal will be the same if the crowd's
going berserk yeah
same and you're what you're doing is
you're pulling away the live experience
of that's a really interesting one
because
um was such
a like focused on the audience performer
to to the very end and he talks about
that
in interviews it's it's clear that he
when he gets out there and he's like
you know hello milwaukee he's not just
like you know reading off a cue card
like some of these bands that have no
idea where the hell they are and they're
like
we always love coming back here because
you're the best you know he
he wouldn't [ __ ] like that you know
whereas i think i think some some other
people might be tempted to do that you
know
in which case they could be
hologrammable you know oh yeah but
there's a difference with dio and
it's so funny like i don't know if you
ever caught a lot of bands i've seen
over the years
they'll ask someone like what's the
major route here and like around me
there's
okay so like this thing would be like we
were coming down route 495
to the show today and the crowd would go
berserk right
yeah see all these and then sometimes
i've heard people
uh name the wrong state they're in
you know that that's happened a couple
of occasions you hear ooh of the crowd
yeah i think you know um what andy says
you know you do want to hear those as
part of a live experience i love those
soon too
acacia avenue i don't think i've ever
heard them do that live
and i love that one i wonder
we saw them here i
i've actually heard them do it live but
it was back in the 90s
we saw them here in 2012 here in
milwaukee i don't remember if they
did it or not oh andy says they did play
it at summerfest 2012.
okay okay yeah um
so that's actually a good segue back you
know another thing that we could
look at as a criterion is what the band
members
or like you know the key band members
thought about the album
so you know um steve harris you know
there's things out there where he says
seventh son of a seventh son is
great stuff and you know he stands
behind it that
you know getting getting steve harris
i think that's probably more important
than going to nico mcbain
or mcbrain and saying what do you think
about it right
and in motorhead obviously what levy
thinks
probably matters more than any other
member although he was always pretty
gracious in letting
whoever else he's got playing with him
to to weigh in on stuff
um and you know i think as i was
thinking about this i thought
and this is something that scott and i
have talked about quite a bit when bands
put together set lists
maybe that's a criterion of not just
what they think the crowd wants to hear
but also what they consider to be their
best material
unless they're like you know feeling
like they're selling out or something oh
we got
it we're warrant we have to put cherry
pie even though we hate playing the song
you know we're stuck playing it um but
when you look at what bands that
and the bands that we're looking at here
these are all bands that could call
their own shots when judas priest goes
out on the road
nobody's really telling them you have to
put this in the setlist you have to put
this on the sidelines
it's up to them if they wanted to do um
you know five editions of green man
alicia i don't think anybody
would stop them right so maybe that's
that's a sign of what's
what they think to be the best or we
could also ask what songs go into
best of or live albums when they're
best of albums that the band themself
produce and not
something that the record company puts
out or they had or somebody else wrote
for a movie soundtrack for them oh right
right
smith aerosmith you'll never hear him
play the diane warren stuff
you raised a great point because iron
maiden
uh they weren't made by radio
you know they weren't they weren't on
the arena they had a hard time getting
on the radio out here in the midwest
well they were yeah i mean like i guess
the only time the only song that really
made it
was wasted years that was on mtv but
besides that
now you take a band like def leppard
where the stereo album
was always on the radio every hour now a
band like def leppard
they feel like they have to play that
whole album which they have since
1988 and why won't buy another ticket um
but iron maiden um on the other hand
they um well when they did a matter of
life and death they played the entire
record of a matter of life and death and
then they played like four or five
of their classic stuff now that's that's
courage to me because
people want to hear run to the hills or
whatever but they bruce dickinson and
steve harris didn't care this is the new
record
behind this so here's an interesting
remark from ken
you know radio never played maiden do
the longer song lengths
i think though there's also another
because we could say well what about
motorhead then i mean they had
they had uh very short songs and some
a lot of it was they just radio stations
weren't going to play
even if they're hard rock they weren't
going to play a lot of metal stuff
unless it was white snake or def leopard
i mean dio was kind of an interesting
exception dio managed to break in
and so and so did um black sabbath
really didn't
but rainbow did you know rainbow's stuff
got got played
especially the jonathan turner stuff
well i'm thinking also like man on the
silver mountain was kind of
for like hard rock stations that was
kind of a staple
um but oh yeah i mean once they went aor
they they're they were all over the
place street dreams you know
yeah what was that uh since you've been
gone
um yup but the new maiden song will
never
be any best you know i haven't heard it
yet yeah
andy and i listen listen to and watch
the video for the new iron maiden song
and it was uh kind of a disappointment
um
but that could be like a whole different
topic for
for another time well you know just to
stay on the subject before we get off
but
every time i saw dio i saw him killing
the dragon tour
he played six songs from that album
magika he played the whole album
and and then uh master of the moon which
was a little more
i don't want to say poppy but like um
i don't know it was more catchy he
played those songs
so dio was you know he wasn't going to
go i was committed to the new music
yeah in other words um uh i was talking
to
a friend that's in a huge metal band
and i was you know kind of complaining
about other band setlists
and he is a joke mentioned a certain
band and said well their new album's not
that good i wouldn't play it either
well that's an interesting thing are you
gonna go
you know we could say greg you and i do
an album and we go hey man i can't wait
to put this out this is the best stuff
we've done
yeah we're gonna play it live because we
believe in it but if we're like hey look
we owe the
record company something let's throw
something together and let's go
to our hit set i mean i think it says a
lot when the band comes out and says
whether you've heard it or not whether
you're going to go to the stand to buy
12 beers or not while we play this stuff
you know but you know but we have this
yeah about
we've talked in the past you know are
you playing for yourself or you're
playing for the
audience i think in the metal case it's
okay to play for yourself because you
have the die hards that have everything
yeah um i will say and
because andy and i have been going to
shows quite a bit pre-covet that
the bands that we've seen really support
their new stuff
and had really good new stuff to support
would be judas priest with the firepower
saxon with the thunderbolt album
uriah heap and i'm blanking on their
what what their
2018 album was i can see like the
picture of it because it's got the
the moon thing um that they played quite
a few songs from
from that which they could have easily
just like stuck to playing you know
20-minute long gypsy or something like
that
um but they were they wanted to play
their new stuff
um who else who else is really
supporting their
their newer stuff um
i'm trying to think i enjoy it even if i
i usually try to get the record first
and listen to it but i enjoy when i go
see that's what we do too yeah
yeah i like you know
let's go back to i don't know the the
age demographic of people that are here
um but i remember going to see bands and
i would always go for the opening band
in the 80s
and i'll never forget and this isn't
metal but
um uh i could probably think of a mental
example but i'll never forget
the band survivor just got rid of the
guy that was on eye of the tiger
and they got this new singer called
jimmy jameson and they had this new
album out called vital signs this was
1985
and i went to see ario speedwagon and
when i went there they played pretty
much
the new album for their hour set and my
jaw was dropped how good the songs were
and
i remember going i came here to see ario
speedwagon but i want to go out and see
if i could buy this album
so you know i think yeah even now if a
band's like hey we're going to play four
for the new album
i'm listening and if it grabs me i'm at
the merch booth
you know wow that was really good so i
think a lot of people won't give it a
chance
um i don't know like how how did you
feel did you have any like
bands kind of like open you're like who
are these guys and then they opening
bands who mean
well you know that's a that's a good
question
um black star writers
played with judas priest and saxon and
black star writers is basically scott
gorham
and so it's it's what it's it's what
thin lizzy transformed into
um because they decided they would they
would play as
thin lizzy but they'd only play thin
lizzy songs and not create any new songs
and then
any new stuff that they would make
because phil linott's been
been dead all this time right um and and
gorham really isn't an original member
you know
he got brought in um so they they they
thought well
we'll we'll have a new band and they're
pretty good you know
um we didn't buy their album
um andy andy says that she did with the
band that opened for ac dc the answer
um oh cool i don't know them
yeah you know well she goes to see ac dc
their mom
so that that's oh that's right a whole
different thing
i remember when and this is interesting
there was a twitter conversation about
acdc
at the madison coliseum in in 1990
and they had love hate there and love
hate
actually got booed off stage because
people
were there to see ac dc and i think love
hate got
like four or five songs in and people
were like you know booing and they left
you know sometimes and and i guess they
were pretty good but they
they weren't what the ac dc crowd wanted
so
it's like what i thought i saw wasted
open for iron maiden
you know yeah i remember you telling me
about this yeah
you know they were more like an aor band
yeah but
i i was really into it they were kind of
polished the harmonies were fantastic
and i actually bought the record but
they didn't make it five songs before
they got boot off stage
yeah and it's kind of sad because they
were there because steve harris really
likes pete way
and i know you know wanted wanted them
to open for them
uh and another funny thing steve harris
is a huge journey fan
so he always says right you know he
always plays journey
for their pa music and people will blew
it from the crowd
and he goes but i'm a big fan i love
that stuff and you know it's kind of
like
you know it might seem a little weird
but it makes sense because i think
you know if we're talking about steve
harris he knows how to write a good song
and he doesn't care what genre it is if
it's
wrong he's going to listen and maybe
pick something
up but i think i it's important with
these metal bands
that it's unlike def leppard they're not
stuck to anything they can do whatever
they want because the crowd
are really diehards the def leppard
people are the
you know people our age that want to
live relive their drunk summer of 1988
or whatever
yeah that's that that's interesting yeah
there's there's being
liberated by your success and then
there's being prisoners of your own
success
all right but that was another
discussion or without having another
discussion on whether
we agree with def leppard on that but
that's that's another day well let's
talk about another another major
criterion that came up and
there's actually a name for this the
killer to filler ratio so you're looking
at the
album and you're looking at all the
tracks
and we could say well how much of the
album is really
solid excellent tracks stuff that you
don't skip
over i think that's one part of it and
then
there's all it needs to have sort of an
integrity as an album
i'm not saying it has to be a concept
album because concept album
they actually get away with that you're
going to listen to the whole album
because otherwise you're missing the
experience right so like operation mind
crime you're not going to skip
over stuff except maybe the vote where
the
people are talking and you're like ah
this is a little bit too over the top
for me
um but you know if you listen to peace
of mind do you skip
over quest for fire or
to tame land or sun and steel or if
you're listening to
iron maiden's number of the beast do you
jump right
over invaders that a lot of people don't
like i mean i listen to the whole album
if i'm listening to the whole album
um but you know like if i'm listening to
ozzy osbourne's
bark at the moon i'm not listening to so
tired you know
no um yeah there's a lot of skip songs
on there for me although
i was a big ultimate sin fan okay i mean
that's that's i think that's a stronger
album actually
yeah i agree but like um
you know uh the two randy rhodes albums
just leave them on
yeah those are those are unbelievable
bad man
i just heard a week ago and i was like
you know you know when it's been years
since you've heard an album you loved
and yeah i went back to that and go wow
this is even better than i thought it
was
you know really stood the test of time
that's a nice that's a nice experience
when you listen to it and you're like oh
there's more going on here
actually i'm gonna indulge in a little
bit of storytelling that goes completely
off topic
so you know scott and i both like
grew up with this music because i think
many of the people involved here
are uh as well and then
by like the mid 90s i you know i was
playing bass
i'd gotten much more into grunge i was
still listening to like some of the 90s
metal like
um you know allison chains and even
weird stuff like prong
you know but i was listening to less and
less of the the classic
stuff and then what got me back into it
was actually
there was a long documentary that had
four parts to it and i think it was vh1
put it out
and it was it was about heavy metal and
i was watching it in the early 2000s
and um
i was i was watching it and listening to
the stuff that they were playing and i
was like
this is actually pretty good musically i
i why did i quit listening to this stuff
and so then i went like on you know cd
buying sprees and i just go to ucd
stores and
like you know if i had friends who who
had a lot i download that onto my
computer
and then you know um just started
listening to more and more and more
and then of course later on discovered
pandora with the
musical genome project and this opened
up massive
things to you know growing up in the
midwest
unless you had money and could go to the
big cities you couldn't get the metal
import stuff very easily i mean you
could order it from
you could order it but it was a total
crap shoot ordering anything
from like circus or hit parader uh stuff
metal blade would have their
their their things and then there'd be
all this european import stuff
but we didn't have the money for that so
there were all these bands and
and uh albums that i'd never actually
heard
and so there there was that that got me
back into it and it was
hearing and saying oh wow there's
something here there's something
more than what i'd remembered um to
bring it back to scott's point
um oh so here's some
so ken ken and chris are posting in
about sun and steel
there is actually a
logger that iron maiden has released
supporting sun and steel
so there's that's a good vote uh
i mean i actually think i i like the
whole piece of mind apple
myself i don't i don't skip stuff but i
know that
some people do pan those those songs uh
that's interesting has anybody tried the
beer
i'm curious i think we bought the
trooper beer a while back
um oh okay back when andy and i were
still living in new york
and i think we had i think we had to
order it if i remember right
that sound right andy maybe through
a liquor store no i think we had to like
order it online
uh what you order like how can how come
you can't be 15 and order it
i i never understood how you could order
alcohol online oh
question it's illegal in massachusetts
well
you i mean you just said massachusetts
you're right not exactly the land of
liberty you know
no oh here's so here's if there's
this is interesting from ken if there's
one track that doesn't really fit the
album
ironically it's the trooper i'd like to
hear why
to me that does that does fit the album
particularly when you put it up with uh
where eagles dare
yeah and die with your boots on um
both lyrically but also musically
um
but let's let's jump to the to back to
this killer to filler ratio so does
does an album have to have no bad songs
in order to be the best album
i would say yeah i i would say you can't
have anything that
is
there's questionable right where people
disagree about it and then there's like
no this is this is not good you know
there's there's
you know and we go back to the aristotle
stuff with contempt
as as a as a fan
in any genre if i bought an album there
was clearly two things put on there
that the band put no thought into or was
a joke song
or it was a really bad cover we never
needed to hear again poorly done
would i just spend 7.99 on you know it's
kind of like you you could have written
two more songs and
um i think initially that you know
there's the the questionable like okay
this was not as strong like you said
and then there's this blatant you you
just ran out of stuff and just said okay
just throw this stuff on and and um you
know like with cassettes
you know well you know with the really
good albums
um they very often
are coming from times when the band was
just totally
fertile you know like like motorhead i
was watching this interview with
um fast eddie clark yesterday and he was
talking about how they were going to the
recording studio and they had too much
material to put onto an album
stuff was just like coming out of them
basically i think that's that's part of
what makes for a great album
oh yeah where uh where people said you
know we we've recorded
you know 20 songs now we've really got
to cut it down and it's going to be
difficult so you know they're going to
take
they're going to be very careful on to
what ends up on the album well
you know just it's funny because um i
guess
was that was the stones record right
before tattoo u was um
but anyways tattoo you when it came out
had all the hits was all the stuff they
wrote for the last album that didn't
make it on the album so they just made
us
they meet tattoo you um yeah
it was all the stuff that didn't make it
on the last album which priest did that
with uh ram it down
a good bit of that was stuff that didn't
make it onto turbo
oh i didn't know that yeah cool
yeah and um there was another band
that did a similar kind of thing and i'm
blanking on it right now
back in the 80s as well um
well let's let's actually we just
brought up judas priests let's talk
about the judas priests polling so we
guess it's moving along
so when i did the polling it was very
interesting
painkiller got the most votes
and then sin after sin british steel
were tied
stained class and then sad wings of
destiny
and painkiller is kind of an outlier in
that way because you look at when when
all these others are coming in and the
others that that did get
votes so um some of the other albums
that people did like
were point of entry
um screaming for vengeance defenders of
the faith
you know everything from sad wings
basically all the way to
defenders of the faith and then turbo
didn't get any
um ram it down didn't get any painkiller
a lot of people felt that to be like a
new resuscitated judas priest and you
look at that album it's really got a lot
of great tracks on it
it's kind of in some ways an advance in
their sound but also return to the
really heavy stuff
the karang vote that paul travers did
this is interesting defenders of the
faith got number one
followed by british steel then
painkiller and then screaming for
vengeance and sin after sin
i'm not sure how he wound up with that
because i i
actually think defenders is a really
great album and that was the first album
that i listened to and i also think
that's their heaviest album
[Music]
but i don't run into too many people who
see things that way
so he must have pulled those people
right
so um what is do you have any reactions
to
this listing or well you know painkiller
is a fantastic alvin i think i
i i mentioned to you that i'd be sh
as great as as an album i thought it
would be disqualified by fans because it
was
was it 1990 right it was later yeah so
it was later and it was kind of like
well to the die hards it's you know
it's always the joke well the early
stuff was the real stuff you know
but painkiller was their heaviest album
up until the one that came out that must
have just punched people in the face it
was just
they were back and i think it was
important it was just kind of like
um you know for a band to have such a
big catalog
to come up with you know you figure okay
our best work's done we'll just do our
best from
here on out for them to make a record
that people go
whoa this is like the best thing you've
done
that's an accomplishment and um it is a
killer album i
i am surprised it came in first well
i think it edged out those others
because the others were dividing
the allegiance between them right so
sin after sin and british steel each got
two-thirds the votes that
painkiller had so you put them together
they've got more votes and then you add
stained class in there
and sad wings of destiny and um
killing machines slash hell bent for
leather and you've got way more than
painkillers so it almost like breaks
down into two eras
or or three eras if we want to say
put sad wings and sin after sin together
and then everything you know from the
late 70s to the 80s
um
chris says victim of change's rules he
wants to hear you play it on guitar
yeah i mean going back to the paint to
the painkiller album it's got painkiller
on it which is always in their set list
yes um
which is i don't want to stop you there
but um as far as
students that are 18 to 20 most of them
are using that as a benchmark to look
cool still i mean
you've got the new guitarist of now but
that's interesting the pain
solo is like they all want to do it for
their proficiency test
well you know um when we got to see
judas priest in concert um there were
there were some times when uh
halford was clearly having some health
problems and then most recently the last
two tours that we've seen them on he he
was firing on all cylinders
and watching him do painkiller
on stage he's using these techniques to
like get the most out of his
his lungs and his body it's like an
athletic performance and i was asking my
my daughter who's a uh you know a vocal
person about this and she was saying
yeah he's doing that for this reason
that for this reason i think that's
probably one of the most demanding vocal
songs
that that judas priest has and it's it's
really to his credit that that rob
halford can still do it today
um so it's interesting to hear that
guitarists are also as as
you know interested in it as vocalists
are and then who
who you know why would the band think in
77 or in 83
that you know wow you know the best
guitar solo i'm going to do is yet to
come in 10 years you know
um yeah it's kind of interesting in that
way but
this is why i kind of brought it up at
the beginning what are the age of the
people
you know if um if you were born in
the year 2000 well you know you're at
least
20 years that album came out 20 years
before you were born
you don't have you didn't we could take
out the criteria a bit of
well you know british steel came out
when i was in high school or anything
it's just
you know they hear it and we used to we
used to drink
beer at bonfires listening to that on
the car stereo yeah yeah
yeah that's a that's a whole lost age i
think it's
but you know that but um kind of like
when we talk about why
i think for the younger generation it's
kind of like it does it's kind of like
you know um i mean led zeppelin was
still playing when i was a kid but
really they didn't get huge until i you
know
the 80s in my school everybody had the
zeppelin albums and to me it didn't
matter because
they didn't come out as i remember like
you know
yeah somebody maybe a generation above
me so i i judge them a little different
i guess that i didn't have the personal
experience with each that came out
yeah well let's let's talk our
two best what do you think is the best
judas priest album
uh i'm gonna go with screen for
vengeance why
the songs are unbelievable i you know uh
and you know turbo is the first one i
heard
because there used to be a metal show
remember you hear metal late at night
right right and when that album came out
turbo was on and i thought it was cool
you know in the sense that
i love this guy's voice and but um
uh so so it's not like a first it's not
like a first album thing
i just think song wise
i mean it's not like there's they're
they're not all great but for some
reason i always go back to that album
um uh you know you've got uh
you've got um well take these chains
remember i was so excited they did it
last
tour and i don't remember them ever
doing it before yeah
um you got another thing coming up that
pre-chorus to me with those guitars are
just
it's just so uh gets me you pumped up
you know oh bloodstone's a great riff
i think every song on that that album is
a great song
um i'm just gonna look at the very
quickly to refresh my
my brain is there is there any filler on
screaming for vengeance i don't think so
although i think i i got a
one that had bonus tracks um i'm looking
it up now
well so the 2001 cd one that had
prisoner of your eyes and devil's child
is that what you're thinking of because
prisoner of your eyes i
actually like that one i think that's
that's a great ballad
um well there's a you know on was it
british and steel
that has that hendrixy kind of ballad um
what's it called summer
why am i blanking
british steel uh it's something summer
why i don't know why i'm blanking out
is it british deal or i don't think so
um god somebody help me out
well in any case um so i i think uh
screaming for vengeance that's
definitely a contender for
for um best album
and i was gonna say sin after sin but i
think i'm gonna agree with you on that
because i i soon after santa's really
really great oh yeah last rose of summer
i just looked it up sorry i mean
in some respects sin after sin has got a
wider
range than screaming for vengeance
does and with less songs um but that one
was like a surprise at first and going
back and listening to that
it's very pretty it's kind of like that
little wing kind of thing on it and
you know what they don't they sound
really good doing it oh
yeah yeah yeah it's not like oh listen
these metal guys try to be sensitive
it's it's uh really cool you know this
and this is like
totally off topic but you know
rob helford is gay and famously
had to you know be in the closet for a
long time
i don't see how anybody doesn't
get that when you listen to sin after
sin you know as andy
pointed out to me a long time ago one
entire song raw deals about going to
fire island and
there's no question that it's it's not
like he's going there to meet some
some woman uh you know it's it's very
clearly about that last rose of summer
could be could be about a love affair
you know that way there was another one
as well but there's also some really you
know awesome
other songs too but but raw deal is a
great song
you know um
well let's let's let's ask people uh
what do you think the best judas priest
oh thank you actually andy i'm sorry i
didn't see you uh chime in thank you
you you did save me before i looked it
up
what do all the rest of you think the
best judas priest album is and why
um yeah i'm dying to know
that was you know these are really hard
for me did you find it really hard
and i remember when you put up the
things i found i found judas priest the
hardest one to decide
myself iron maiden would be like maybe
the second hardest to decide
um for for except in do
it wasn't it wasn't it it was sort of
like a automatic gut reaction uh for me
and i'm gonna have surprise ones for
those i'll probably be like
all right so so uh andy says she gave up
trying to decide
ken said painkiller is an obvious choice
but it's less cerebral than their
earlier stuff yeah painkiller
was their heaviest but i agree ken
that's that's an interesting point i
would say defenders is heavier
you but you think painkiller is a
heavier album than defenders well here's
the
okay so this is where um
greg usually brings me in um sonically
because um where we're at 1990
um there's now production techniques and
effects and
new hands on the market that you know
there could be more distortion on the
guitar
um there's you know different vocal
effects where it's uh
the production is actually making it
heavy as well as the band's performance
okay if you go back to let's just say
early albums from the mid 70s any band
put two mics in the middle of the room
and just go well they're using what they
have like you know technology hasn't
gone that far yet and it wasn't so
1990 wasn't too different it was just
you were in the production
you know um the way they would mix the
snare or whatever they would
you know the way the guitars came
through in the past they'd pan them and
have less gain the bass would push it
and by 1990 production trends have
changed so
um you know what would what we've
decided is
is if we had them play both albums in
their entirety
live and then we can decide oh
you know like so we would get today's
present day
rig that they have all they have the
guitarist and everything yeah
well you know what greg you're right
that is a heavier album but like the
tune painkiller is just
really heavy the tune itself
yeah well that's the one that kind of
stands out
whereas with um
killer no well with defenders of the
faith right
so free will burning jawbreaker uh
the sentinel um some heads are gonna
roll
oh yeah those are all like super heavy
and even um night comes down which is
their ballad on there
even that is is a heavy heavy ballot
it's not like
a lot of the stuff that was being it's
just slower it's
it's not it's not really a balance
um it's it's just a slower song um
so i don't know yeah i i mean i i would
say that
one of the things that changes in terms
of heaviness
is um in terms of technique is
the drumming from mid 80s to like 90s
you know
using the the like very precise
drumming you hear that in a lot of metal
bands it's almost like there's too much
drumming going on you know
that's one way to make things heavier um
with the bass drums
yeah between 1980 and 1990 a lot of
thrash
was coming out right right and a double
kick drum and uh
yeah um so
are there are there any like important
innovations in terms of base
stuff around that time or or not or is
that just basically following what the
guitars are doing
uh well you mean as far as uh an
approach to playing
yeah and making things sound heavier i
mean or are they just using the same
like you know echoing the riff pedal
notes the same kind of stuff as was done
in the early
80s i you know
so greg will know this too but um a
classic
i think for any genre my favorite sound
is
a fender bass through an ampeg and you
would turn the ampeg up loud
and it would push the tubes and you get
a growl out of it and
lemmy's an extreme example of that well
he actually had distortion
okay yeah um i think the classic
use of bass in the 70s and early 80s is
the heaviest sound
because it was very clear it had some
hair on it
yeah he started to get not it with
everybody of course but
they started to clean up in the mixes so
it could cut through it a different way
because
it's got that more tubular sound to it
it was yeah it was just
so and then like in the 90s i remember
everybody having these
like new uh trace elliott amps with bass
and it was cleaner
and it would cut through the mix but i
was like i don't like that and then when
i went on a gig with a bass player with
the
ampeg i said now we're talking yeah no
it's
uh just for heaviness sake we have some
more weigh-ins on the judas priest so
chris
says sand wings and screaming because
all killer no filler
i love it that's true i mean
there's i think there's a lot of judas
priest albums that we can say that about
um where there just isn't a bad song on
them and then ken says sad wings is
definitely an all-time classic heavy
rock album defenders also had an amazing
mastered mix for the time that's
interesting it does actually
yeah i mean i like um we were talking
about
vocal effects um
i brought it up with motorhead but um
where
turbo was kind of it's kind of like they
backed off
the processing pad like after turbo like
heads are going to roll that intro
is so nasty that guitar intro yeah yeah
such a great riff
and you know and then you almost hear
like a slap back
on halford's voice and it's it's not
super complicated but it gives you this
like when you listen to heads are going
to roll
or stuff anything off that album it's
kind of almost a 3d
sound there's depth to it yeah like
you know talk about getting lost into
the tune in with the headphones
you know entering a world i do agree
that the i really like the mastering on
that album
you know the mastering as you're
pointing out is just so absolutely
central to whether an album is going to
punch through or not so you know i think
about peace of mind and number of the
beasts really great at the time
um by contrast black sabbath's 1983
uh born again great album great songs on
there
and what holds it back is the bad
mastering
you know you have the mixing and the
mastering and if you screw either of
those two up
yeah um it's lackluster
yeah i mean i i do have to mention
that the the tour that followed okay
that was messed up that actually like
some stuff figured into spinal tap you
know um
ian gillen had trouble you know
memorizing the lyrics and stuff like
that but the album itself is really
really good
you know um but it could have been so
much better
you know let's talk about motorhead
um so the polling that i did ace of
spades basically ran away with it i
would say
and then um people did say no sleep for
hammer cement until
hammersmith we're gonna put that aside
overkill came in at number two
and then bomber 1916 and bastards
um louder sound did a survey
and they also had ace of spades overkill
bomber motorhead and another perfect day
so ace of spades i think that's probably
the one that most people
know the most and overkill it's nice to
see
that in number two on both and then
bomber um
it's good to see another perfect day get
get some love because it's it's quite a
good um
quite a good album it's it's kind of a
weird one-off because it's brian
robertson who only plays on
on one album and then you know he's sort
of a transitional figure between
the fast eddie phil taylor motorhead and
then the later
um virtual phil campbell and then
whoever's gonna drum
motorhead uh that that we know
so what do you make of these
these choices should ace of spades run
away with it you think or
i mean i i understand why ace of spades
ran away with it
i mean um it's the one i know the best
um and actually i went back i have a few
of them i don't have
the catalog i'm not you know like maiden
i have the whole catalog
but i did under but i did enjoy going
through the the whole process or the you
know
some of the albums i never heard before
just yeah um
i just figured like listening to them
now we go back to what we talked we
started this whole
uh subject with today and it's well ace
of spades
um was the one everybody seemed to know
and talk about but then when i looked at
their discography i'm going oh my god
i didn't even know about this album yeah
they have they have a
massive catalog following that and i
think i think with
quite a few classic metal bands we'd see
it kind of gravitating towards the
old end and then like you know if you
ask like what's the best saxon album
right i don't think people are gonna say
thunderbolt or
really any anything after like uh
strong arm of the law or you know
they're they're only gonna know the 80s
stuff for the most part
i mean like denim and leather was mine
today
great album but like you know they've
got they got went on to get much heavier
and um put out albums after that but uh
i wonder if that stuff still exists in
their set um denim and leather that
album oh
yeah they they did they did play stuff
for him oh cool
yeah um i was going to be
sorry um i was going to say um one of
the things that i think i met
um mentioned to you that was interesting
is
lemmy's vocal treatment on let's say ace
of spades and then
um just jumping a few years ahead to
another perfect day
yeah um now we're seeing what you know
there was a an effect called the the
boss ce1
and it was a chorus and a chorus pedal
is like
a slight modulation means it slightly
detuned stuff to give it depth
and there was something about the ce1
the the chips they actually used to
build the effect
actually gave it kind of a slapback
effect and it sounds like on another
perfect day lemmy's using it and i think
it sounds
really cool and um but the thing is they
can't duplicate that sound because i
guess those chips don't exist anymore
so either you find the old gear to
duplicate that sound so that's kind of a
cool thing that
yeah the i you know i think another
perfect day is a great album
um but very just a three year difference
seeing how things change
production wise i mean really 80 wasn't
82 or 83 when
journey came out with um frontiers and
it's like no record we heard before with
all this
you know chorus and reverb and all this
stuff i really think the trend hit right
around 83
and we're kind of hearing that even with
motorhead
um and then you know if they go on they
could go back to whatever they want
sound rather than um you know
something new you got for christmas you
know like oh hey the record company's
not gonna put it out unless you have
this new sound the kids like
[Laughter]
i don't know what it was with motorhead
but you know you do hear it in trends
during the eighties
well they they they're definitely not a
a group that was going to play nice with
the record company on that sort of thing
no but i think but but maybe maybe what
that's why it sounds so good because
lemmy
tried it out and said this this sounds
great you know like
i can usually tell the year of if
somebody plays me something from the 80s
i'll tell you what year it came out by
the production it's because
most of the time and people play that
game with me and i just know the trends
because
yeah when you're young the years are
long
and um and that would be a fun game to
play sometime here
actually yeah we wouldn't be able to do
run the video because as soon as uh any
of the song stuff came up we'd get
immediately flagged on
on youtube so what what what did you
pick as the best motorhead album
did you pick ace of spades or ace of
spades okay
and this mostly because of your criteria
i'm most familiar
um iron fist was i listen that's
killer yeah that's a great album great
album um
uh and i and i'm gonna admit to maybe
it's not the great
album you know i'm admitting that i know
maiden and priest way better than
motorhead
but i did listen to all that stuff and
take notes and go this is a great album
you know this is a great album and i'm
i'm thinking between like
um 80 and 83 because iron fist was like
uh
between two it was it was between those
two wasn't it yeah 82.
yeah yeah so um
yeah it's it's but the ace of spades i
mean
it and i'm picking it basically because
most familiar and i do
love the album i had a hard time with
this
um i know you're a much bigger motorhead
fan that's
oh yeah overkill bomber and ace of
spades
all three of them kind of jockey for
position in part because there are so
many
great classic motorhead songs on them
the ones that really like stick in your
head you know the ones that are like
absolutely classic motorhead that they
continued playing
throughout their their uh their time as
they kept churning out new stuff
um but i'm actually gonna go with
overkill and the reason i'm gonna go
with overkill
is a little bit quirky um it's got two
songs on it that are motorhead songs but
a little bit different than their usual
fare they've got capricorn
and metropolis and they're both much
more jazzy
and trippy and they allow fast eddie
clark
who's got this really distinctive both
style of playing and also like effects
he's got a lot of
reverb on um it's he's a
very lyrical kind of player um
they let him really shine
especially capricorn you know the solos
on that
um those that's that's the one that i
would pick
although the rest of these are great and
even you know even the stuff that comes
after it um i
i i can't think of a bad motorhead album
frankly
you know yeah throughout their
discography one where you're like oh
this is this is a misstep
you know do you remember um
there's this um maybe chris uh ken
i'm sorry we'll know um remember years
ago i said that british comedian that
had that show
and he had these famous you know like
david gilmour come out
and like play another brick in the wall
and he was arguing
a court case to a judge that there was
they weren't having the right pictures
on in the music to make it easy to play
the songs like the finger diagrams
and no i don't remember this at all
david gilmore would come out and
he's an exhibit a so he puts it in front
of david gilmour and david gilmore's
struggling to play another brick of the
wall because he can't read and like
what's the problem he goes well they
don't have the pictures where i put my
fingers
and lemmy comes out next and i
i wanted to know if you knew what like
he was playing um
he came out to play uh one of their
famous one of his most famous bass riffs
and they go
okay um now you play in and let me say
well i can't mate
uh there's no pictures like so pictures
and they bring out mark
knopfler they bring out um all these
people and they can't read
they can't read their own music because
you know um
does ken does this ring a bell at all
it's it's a
um it was i don't know if it was a tv
show it looked like it might it was the
90s
um but it was hysterical but i'm trying
to remember
they said you know oh they dipped into
heavy metal and then they brought lemmy
out and he's playing
you would recognize the riff in a second
and i don't remember what it was
not not top of the pops this was um top
of the pops is a
this was like a comedy show chris says
french and saunders tv show
i mean that sounds familiar be right
it's the
him and his dad are in all the skits
right okay
i'll have to resend it to you okay yeah
that sounds that sounds great
let's talk a little bit other um key
criteria that we i think we've brought
up already
but we're heading towards having sort of
a resolution
so you know the judas priest the iron
maiden the motorhead you notice there's
but then this gravitation
towards like the classic era of the band
with
painkiller being a little bit of an
outlier on that
um and i would say that these bands when
they're producing their best albums
they're
like their their talent is really ripe
they've gone through the music industry
bs and kind of come out on the other
side
and they're all playing together
properly you know they're they're
the band is not you know falling apart
or anything like that
sometimes it could be growth on the part
of the band adding bruce dickinson in on
vocals
you know definitely changed iron maiden
um
so maybe there's maybe one of the
criteria i'm not sure exactly what to
call
this in terms of you know single
words but something like
the band is all there the band is firing
on all cylinders the band is
in their most productive time you know
and some of these bands have had
that could be a whole decade some of
these bands that might be
a narrower uh amount of time
yeah but it is it is interesting that
it's a classic one although
i almost thought i wouldn't have been
shocked
if iron maiden's um
brave new world their comeback album
with adrian smith
did that make it anywhere because that
was uh there were there were a few
people
um killers actually got more than that
um and killers is kind of an outlier as
well
but yeah there were a few people who
singled that one out ray i mean what
that was like you know i remember when
it came out i had low expectations but
the fact that it was that was no filler
to me it was yeah
the live their show they did the first
four songs were from that album
and it was amazing so um it's not like
maiden wasn't still writing great
records yeah
i don't know we do equate the early
stuff right
the classic uh or you know um
it's almost like the band's ethos gets
kind of established
at that time and then people will be
like ah
this new stuff it's not really like it
or oh it's another motorhead album but
it's just another motorhead album
you know and there'll be like a few
songs off of like say 1916 or bastards
that people will
bring up um or overnight sensation you
know was was
another good one but but none of them
have like the presence of
ace of spades or um
i mean and i would say that happened to
motorhead already by rock and roll
which is 19 i want to say 1986 1987.
people were like oh it's good it's
motorhead it's a reliable
quantity but you know we're really here
to hear
this this other stuff um that's the one
andy
sorry oh andy posted the oh gary moore
that would be funny
everybody should watch that okay it's
one of i
i died whoever thought of that it's uh
and they
and the fact that they got all of these
guitarists to show up to the show and
you know make fun of them and ham it ham
it up right yeah well they were making
fun of themselves
and uh um they were all great and
yeah so the lenny one you're gonna have
to let me know um i forget
they announce it um they announce it
like you know the song that they come
out
yeah like they play a bit of it and then
they put the music now with the music
and they can't you know for younger
people who are watching too we should
probably mention
the young ones as a tv show and the fact
that motorhead
appeared not in their ace of spades
lineup they
by that time they were actually a four
piece with uh virtual and phil
phil campbell but they played ace of
spades on the young ones and i think
that's part of what established ace of
spades is such a
well that's a landmark song you know
well that's interesting
yeah oh yeah i mean a lot of people say
if you get your song on a show
it'll take off it doesn't matter how old
it is you know
another we should actually do some
research on this because i'm sure
there's a lot more shows out there i
remember when anthrax came on married
with children
and played that really heavy song
they've got what is it
is it my life in my life
it was off a persistence of time album
and i was like holy crap this is
like motorhead playing on the the young
ones you know
yeah yeah and i'm sure there's lots of
examples out there of
bands doing that and the songs will take
off it's i remember when we were kids
um was in the early 80s that movie the
big chill
yeah and it had all the music from the
like the motown era stuff
it was only 20 years old but that's how
everybody in
in school knew of the temptations that
everybody because the big chill was
i think reservoir dogs did that there
were a lot of people in the 90s who had
the reservoir dogs um
[Music]
soundtrack you know let's let's talk
about let's talk a bit more about
polling
we have two more bands to hit on so deo
is a little bit different right because
i didn't specify just dio albums
in my polling holy diver blew everything
out of the
out of the water you know way more way
more votes for holy diver than for
anything else
but then people also said rainbow rising
uh so you know with richie blackmore's
rainbow
mob duels with black sabbath and then
the the two stragglers were magicka and
angry machines
magicka got some love i like that now in
louder sound
and this is this is really interesting
they picked
heaven and hell black sabbath with
without ronnie james ceo
holy diver second and then
the three rainbow albums rainbow rising
rainbow and long live rock and roll so
not a
not a single other deal album in the mix
um so i don't know who louder sound was
polling but that's weird to me
you know those rainbow albums are great
right
but i mean do you think that the deo
albums aren't better than the rainbow
albums or
you know and that's funny because i
remember when you put it up
us talking wait a minute we didn't make
the distinction right right
just dio and and it became fair game
before we know it
yeah um and with somebody like you i
think it makes sense because his
he was established as a solo
artist in part by being in rainbow he
says this in his interviews you know he
learned a lot from
uh richie blackmore and from tony aomi
for better and
worse yeah and then he also he also you
know brought his drummer
from uh um black sabbath
and he brought in some members too like
jimmy bain came to deal right from
rainbow so you know he poached people
he learned that from ricky for richie
blackmore i guess you know
take other people's uh musicians away
from them so i think it's it is fair
game
you know um
yeah it's it's yeah i mean uh jimmy bain
for for years i mean i have that killing
the dragon live dvd jimmy baines right
there
yeah doug aldrich on guitar um
which was a great lineup we could talk
about the different deal lineups with
craig goldie versus vivian
yeah um
yeah jimmy bain sort of like a bob
daisley who they moved in the same
circles right really great
basis willing to i think there's
something about being able to play in
other people's bands
and contribute that um there's maybe
something to be explored there
you know not have you listen to jimmy
bain you listen to bob daisley
you can recognize them in their
baselines as doing what they're doing
they never have a stable home like say
you know steve harris did or ian hill
and
and jewish priest um and so they're like
you know kind of like ultimate session
players
um and they i haven't heard a bad song
come
out of either of them you know well it's
apparent with ozzie's rhythm section
including randy rhodes on the first
couple albums yeah
you know um with tommy eldridge it's
just uh you know i always say
all-star players or the band won't be
good it's
i always joke about um
well um bands where you put together all
the stars
it's tough to pull off a good one
that'll last more than an album or two
yeah but it doesn't mean they play well
together and ken may agree with me
um uh just because i use the the
football reference or soccer
um brazil has some of the greatest uh
soccer players in the world
but they don't win games so it's the
same with the band you oh
you've got you know steve harris and
then you've got some drummer and they
might not agree on the time and it just
doesn't gel
yeah so there's something you said like
a band like you two sound those records
sound
amazing are they great technical
musicians no but they
spent eight hours a day playing together
and they figured it out
it sounds like a band so um
a team of prima donnas does not
necessarily a good band
and i'm italian again i'm sorry my
brother um
my partner she's from london from north
london so we watched the game together
last week and
i had to sleep on the couch
i got my family's from italy so scott
who what do you think is the best d.o
album and why
um okay nobody's gonna agree with me on
the sacred heart
okay why that's all it's all amazing
tunes those songs
king of rock and roll the two sacred
hearts just really kind of
haunting with that riff um vivian's
playing
really melodic solos i think he's got
you know
you know vivian played so great and
unique besides last in line which was
probably my favorite solo he did
um he just would hold on to a note and
kind of
i just um i know there were keyboards
and stuff on it but i think
it's it's it song wise
it's my favorite album and it's too bad
vivian didn't
really do the tour after because greg
goldie was is a fine guitar player but
vivian was just perfect for that era
and then i'd have to say if i had to
pick a second it would i would go with
heaven and hell
okay what a what a just amazing amazing
album
i mean some of the people who weighed in
were talking about
like the the rainbow or sabbath era
stuff and saying well
you know you've got him with tony aomi
you know
and geezer butler and that that
adds in something that his own solo band
couldn't couldn't provide
i would say it's different i don't know
that i would say that's
that's better but because because dio
was able to put together some really
killer
bands you know and i think with dio
once it became his name on the marquee
he wasn't going to half-ass
anything that's true yeah you know um
yeah we don't really see a bad album
from deal although he does he said he
doesn't like
um what's the one after that um
craig goldie's first album a dream evil
yeah
and but all the full sail away that's a
good one yeah yeah i mean
uh dream evil's a great soon but you
know he he was somehow wasn't pleased
with that album
uh dio was it but i thought it was a
maybe not his best but there's some
strong songs on that album
yeah performance is great yeah
so i picked i picked um
last in line i mean i really like holy
diver it was the first album that i had
um and
i think lassen line is a better album uh
a great record
there's no yeah there's not a bad song i
mean there's not a bad song on on either
of them
um but some of the songs for me
like i speed at night um egypt
you know egypt gets me every time you
know um
evil eyes you know uh and beginning with
we rock
although i mean uh holy diver
um beginning with stand up and shout i
mean dio knew how to start an album
oh yeah goes with that sometimes and
wow yeah those are great
yeah so that that's an interesting one
what what are the rest of you think
what's what's the best deal
album and you can say black sabbath or
rainbow albums if you want to
bring those in um i mean let's actually
say
what what's what while people are
thinking about it scott what would you
say is the best uh
rainbow album that does on
um
the best rainbow album well they see
again we can't pick the live stuff
because there's performance on the
livestream out of this world
yeah so i understand that you know like
greg and i both say you can't nobody can
pick a greatest hits album
the reason we can't pick a greatest hits
album is because it's taking stuff from
different ears and different snapshots
of time
whereas a live album you're taking one
snapshot of a night
or a few nights on that tour yeah but
you're using songs from
but rainbow rising i would say rising
too
yeah oh here's so ken says mob rules
it's the finest doom
metal album ever recorded that's
interesting that's cool
um because you think of like older
sabbath as as doom metal but i guess
mob rules i guess it does fit in there
yeah um not dio's best vocal performance
but as a whole album it's timeless
perfection
it is i mean both of the albums he did
with well i mean
he also did uh dehumanizer later on with
with
with uh black sabbath but that's a later
era
i mean both of those two bridge albums
between rainbow and dio are
pretty amazing stuff you know
yeah why you know just back to dio's
you know um watching the interviews he
doesn't sugarcoat anything
no i just you know i love it we love
them for that they the first question
they asked the interview is
um what happened to black sabbath
because remember he joined us with
heaven and hell
yeah apparently he didn't want to open
on oz fest for ozzy
why would he i mean ozzy was a complete
jerk to him and had no reason to be
and he said and he goes and i tell you i
knew it was going to happen they just
wanted him to come back in the band
anyway so
yeah you know like and i love how he
doesn't go well you know
we had some differences of opinion he's
just
you know and um and there's a there's
such an honesty to him and i think
live there's that honesty where you know
when he did say like you know
like you know what when he does uh go
talk to strangers and then he
he says why and he puts it in the mic to
the audience and
we all scream and and uh he goes you get
it right every time
and it's just kind of like you know like
you said earlier you never feel like
he's giving you a put on
when when you're in the audience you
know you just you feel like he's really
connecting with the audience and like
thank you thank you okay yeah and i'll
be like point over and
i think he's one of the more sincere
performers like he took every show
really seriously rather than
and i just feel that way with his albums
i'm saying too it's kind of like
um just self pride but also
you know you you you buy your ticket you
buy my album
um i'm gonna do money's worth so that's
that i guess that
you know his personality and everything
just the whole deal package
he was a catalyst in many
respects a catalyst is is something that
that brings things out of a precipitate
to a lot
out of a compound to allow them to
precipitate out so
somebody who could bring potentiality to
actuality and to do so
by coaching them you know and by
insisting on limits and things like that
i mean we could
actually do a whole episode on dio
sometime that might be something
to talk about i would actually say that
he he
more than anybody in the field of heavy
metal except for maybe steve harris
exemplifies what aristotle calls the
architect tone
the um the the maker
who influences all the other makers and
a range of things so the word we get
architect from
oh so but we'll put that off let's talk
about accept before we have to
sign off pretty soon so except
uh the polling people were kind of worn
out i think we didn't get many results
and most people just said restless and
wild we did have
one person who said balls to the wall uh
fairly recently so it's kind of
interesting you know nobody said metal
heart
nobody said any of the more recent stuff
you know since udo
left uh way way back and they you know
got like mark tornillo as
as a vocalist um
so let's talk except what would you say
is their best album
me yeah um metal
i knew i could i know it was going to be
like a an unpopular one
um it's funny because
uh we go back to the market i told you
the story greg so
in 1985 when the album came out there
was a tower records right in boston and
and
with every purchase you got a 45
of um the song metal heart and the b
side was screaming for a love bite okay
and i went home and i
listened to it so much i i you know
i i went back i didn't have my license i
had my mom drive me
and i bought the album and um
i got into him that way like there's a
first album then you buy other albums
but yeah um
this the songs are really strong on
there they
they transferred great when you know
with udo live i mean when they played
it's
just um uh
there's some of their really strong
songwriting i mean boss the wall is a
great album
um but yeah metal heart and i don't i
don't know
i'm surprised anybody else said that
because i'm thinking like you know some
people
accuse me of you like yeah there's the
truly albums that are like the outskirts
that are like the less popular ones but
i don't know
was that a did you think battle heart
was a big one
i would have expected to see more people
say that they
thought it was the the best um
i i think that restless and wild balls
the wall metal heart those three are
probably
they should be the top three um right i
actually listened to russian roulette
the other day
and that album does hold up that's the
one that's the last one that they did
with uh udo but nothing from it
um really gets into playlists um and
then the earlier stuff like i like
breaker and i like
uh i'm a rebel um and and i do like the
stuff that accept has done
you know uh since the split with with
udo we saw them on the blind rage tour
a lot of stuff off of that and
stalingrad are good
i want to say balls to the walls the
best album
is hard because love child is such a
great great tune
well it's full of great songs
so balls to the wall london leather boys
fight it back head over heels which has
been covered by a lot of other bands
losing more than you've ever ever had is
a great song
that's just the first side and then love
child okay if there's a weakest song on
it it's probably turned me on
um but then losers and winners i
actually use that with andy
uh you know when we're joking around and
something goes wrong i say write a
letter
you know you'll feel better you know
it's it's become sort of a trope
and then you know guardian of the night
and winter dreams both a little bit more
ballady but
still really really heavy and and you
know um
restless and wild is great but i i just
don't think it's as
good as balls to the wall myself but
um i might be an outlier um what do the
rest of you think what's
the best accept album
well just you know udo was uh
the unexpected great front man i mean he
oh
yeah he had everything that you you if
you saw him on paper
if you read about him we don't want this
guy you know
yeah yeah collage pants and uh and
for lack of a better word just kind of
like you know
uh you adore the guy he just you know he
he with that voice you know his rant
voice you know he had a normal voice but
he had that screaming voice all that
time
and yeah yeah and it's just like yeah
and
you know we we have to talk about you
know how the rant felt
fits into heavy metal like paul stanley
yeah you know
um the stories but in that in the in
their character voice
you know uh andy and i both saw accept
and udo um
separately obviously uh within like a
year of each other
in in new york we saw except down at the
gramercy
with raven and we saw udo
with his own band at the chance in
poughkeepsie
and both were amazing shows although
there it was kind of interesting to see
the tension between
uh wolf hoffman who seems to be kind of
a jerk
and um herman frank who
quit soon afterwards along with the
drummer um
now you know um uh pete even peter
baltis is left um
except so it's just basically whoever
um wolf hoffman hires around him and and
mark
tonil on lyrics but udo had all these
younger guys
i mean he was in his 60s when we saw him
he
clearly loved what he was doing and all
these younger guys were like clearly
into
playing both the udo stuff f post accept
and the accept standards it was an
amazing show
all right so ken says balls is probably
the better album from a musical and
writing perspective
but restless literally invented the
european thrash scene so it is
unquestionable influence on so many
subsequent bands yeah i would you know i
would say balls to the walls more
straight ahead classic metal um and
it's not it's not as fast it is i think
it's heavier
but it's it's not as fast as fast fast
as
um restless in a while that one's called
the fast as a shark
it's just one of the socks on it um
yeah well that's interesting about the
you know
um what ken is saying you know he's kind
of using one of the criteria is
it's an important album yeah he feels
that that's something we were talking
about earlier
and yeah specifically it will thrash so
i mean this is another thing we can
explore
i i want to do a session just on the
thrash
early thrash metal because when we were
hearing this stuff speed thrash
were they different were they the same
it was really hard to tell sometimes
it really depended on who you were
talking to almost and then thrash became
its own
thing but super indebted to what we
would call speed metal which was never
itself a really coherent
genre you know like you could say
motorhead with speed metal is iron
maiden speed metal yeah
kind of you know but there were other
bands where you'd be like well this is
much more
speed metal except was was at the you
know the center of that as well
so yeah you know we have to think about
the times
um ken says i think restless is the
european rain and blood
um very interesting i mean because it
would certainly antidate it you know
he's referring to slayers right right
yeah i mean slayer is actually
in some respects a little bit of a late
comer compared to
metallica anthrax megadeth um
they definitely are positioning
themselves we're gonna play faster than
those guys you know we're
we're gonna try to be heavier than those
guys um except
is is predating all of them
as as his motorhead so well that's
interesting because
um i think a lot of people credit slayer
as the um the innovators or
if they're more educated it's kind of
how they referred to bach
that like bach didn't invent baroque
music but when he died it ended because
he mastered it
okay you know and it's kind of like
slayer
took these and then took it to the next
level
um i i think if you know this is why
it's important who you ask if you ask
somebody
like ken who's aware of what happened
before slayer
yeah and you know slayer if you
just say the word slayer oh that's the
that's the thrash speed whatever
the band yeah oh wait a minute wait a
minute you know these other bands were
doing it too
you know but they just kind of took that
all and
you know like you said you know we're
going to be faster
faster louder was the joke back then
right yeah
yeah we're we're going to be so fast
that nobody can actually you know
hear us play well that was um that was
napalm death right
yeah i mean you you reach you reach a
certain sort of
you know point of diminishing return
when when you
make those criteria um
the key thing well that's interesting uh
ken says an argument could be made for
dissident aggressor by priest being the
first
speed metal track possibly
possibly so yeah we that's something i
think we'd have to devote a lot more
thought to so this is a great segue for
bringing this to a close
uh we went a little bit over our our
expected time but some great
conversation
thanks to everybody who joined and
contributed
um once again thanks always to you scott
for
showing up and contributing uh not just
your enthusiasm but your technical
expertise
yeah it's my pleasure i have a blast at
these yeah
so um we will be doing thrash sometime
down the line
um but i'm not sure quite when we
haven't yet decided what the next topic
is going to be
but i do think we'll probably do more
polling down the line as well
with thinking about like you know 1970s
metal
what were the best albums you know maybe
thrash
um maybe some other things as well
yeah i mean there's so much every time
we do one of these we
we we go off into a subject that has
that's what we're talking about
but saying that's where we open up a lot
of cans of worms
well you know that's that's the great
thing about these discussions because
the fact that we're discussing and we
have people with great perspective on
that
um it's something that i didn't think
about
and that's the kind of the point of the
discussion is throw things in and go you
know what we got to save this for
another one
and really i think a lot of these you
know even this one came
out of another one right right you know
kind of like well
we can't talk about what the best is
that's a whole other thing
there's a whole other show or you know
of us you know what is the criteria we
can't talk about that right now
and so we got to talk about it today
yeah
all right well let's let's wrap up
thanks to everybody and
uh you know keep listening to the heavy
stuff
yeah take care everyone
you